[Music]
he also saw the Rusia they had come to
trade and had disembarked at the atill
River I have never seen bodies as nearly
perfect as theirs as tall as palm trees
fair and reddish they wear neither
tunics nor calf dance every man was a
cloak with which he covers half his body
so that one arm is uncovered they carry
axes swords and daggers and always have
them to hand they use Frankish swords
with broad ridged blades they are dark
from the tips of their toes right up to
their necks with trees pictures on the
like every woman was a small box made of
iron
silver brass or gold depending on her
husband's financial Worth and social
standing
tied at her breasts the box has a ring
to which a knife is attached also tied
at her breasts the women wear neck rings
of gold and silver when a man has
amassed ten thousand dirhams he has a
neck ring made for his wife when he's
amassed twenty thousand dirhams he has
two neck rings made for every subsequent
10,000 he gives a neck ring to his wife
this means a woman can wear many neck
rings the jewelry they prized the most
is the dark ceramic beads that they have
aboard their boats and which they trade
amongst themselves they purchase beads
for one dirham each and string them
together as necklaces for their wives
they are the filthiest of God's
creatures they have no modesty when it
comes to defecating or urinating and do
not wash themselves when intercourse
puts them in a state of ritual impurity
don't even wash their hands after eating
indeed they are like roaming asses they
arrive more their boats by the a tail
and build large wooden houses on its
banks they share a house in groups of 10
and 20 sometimes more sometimes fewer
each reclines on a couch they are
accompanied by beautiful female slaves
for trade with the merchants they have
intercourse with their female slaves in
full view of their companions sometimes
they gather in a group and do this in
front of each other
a merchant may come in to buy a female
slave and stumble upon the owner having
intercourse the ruse does not leave her
alone until he has satisfied his urge
they must wash their faces and heads
each day with the filthiest water you
can imagine let me explain every morning
a female slave brings a large basin full
of water and hands it to her master he
washes his hands face and hair in the
water then he dips the comb in the water
and combs his hair then he blows his
nose and spits in the basin he is
prepared to do any filthy impure act in
the water when he is finished the female
slave carries the basin to the man next
to him who performs the same routine as
his comrade she carries it from one man
to the next and goes around to everyone
in the house every man blows his nose
and spits in the basin and then washes
his face and hair they disembark as soon
as their boats dock each carries bread
meat onions milk and alcohol to a large
block of wood set in the ground the
piece of wood has a face on it the face
of a man it is surrounded by small
figurines placed in front of large
blocks of wood set in the ground he
prostrates himself before the large
figure and says Lord I have come from a
distant land with such-and-such a number
of female slaves and such-and-such a
number of sable pelts he lists all his
merchandise then he says and I have
brought this offering
he leaves his offering in front of the
piece of ward saying I want you to bless
me with a rich merchant with many
dinners and Durham's who will buy from
me whatever I wish and will not haggle
over any price I said then he leaves if
he finds it hard to sell his goods and
has to stay there too many days he comes
back with a second and third offering if
his wishes are not fulfilled he brings
an offering to every single figurine and
seeks his intercession saying these are
the wives daughters and sons of our Lord
he goes up to each figurine in turn and
petitions it begging for its
intercession and groveling before it
sometimes business is good and he makes
a quick sale in that case he says my
Lord has satisfied my request so I need
to compensate him he acquires some sheep
or cows and kills them gives a portion
of the meat as arms and places the rest
before a large block of wood and small
ones around it ties the head of the cows
or the sheep to the piece of wood set up
in the ground when night falls the dogs
come and eat it all up and the man who
has gone to all this trouble says My
Lord is pleased with me and has eaten my
offering
when one of them falls ill a pitch a
tent far away and lay him down inside
with some bread and water they do not
approach him or speak to him indeed they
have no contact with him for as long as
he is ill especially if he's a social
inferior or if he recovers and gets back
onto his feet he rejoins them if he dies
they set fire to him they do not bury
dead slaves but leave them as food for
the dogs and the birds when they catch a
thief or a bandit they take him to a
solid tree and put a sturdy rope around
his neck they tie him to the tree and he
hangs there until he eventually
decomposes from exposure to the rain and
the winds I was told that they set fire
to their chieftains when they died
sometimes they do more so I was very
keen to verify this then I learned to
the death of a very important man they
placed him in his grave with a roof
raised over him for 10 days while they
finished cutting and sewing his garments
when the deceased is poor they build a
small boat for him place him inside it
and burn it when he is rich they collect
his possessions and divide them into
three portions one-third goes to his
household one-third is spent on his
funeral garments and one-third is spent
on the alcohol they drink the day the
female slave kills herself and is
cremated with her master they are
addicted to alcohol they drink it night
and day sometimes one of them dies cup
in hand when the chieftain dies the
members of his household ask his female
and male slaves who will die with him
one answers I will at this point the
words become binding there is no turning
back it's not even an option it's
usually the female slaves who offer
when my man I just mentioned died they
said to his female slaves who will die
with him once said I will so they put
two other female slaves in charge of her
caring for her and accompanying her
wherever she went even to the point of
washing her feet with their hands then
they attended to the chieftain cutting
his garments and setting in order what
was required for him
the female slave drank alcohol every day
and sang merrily and cheerfully I
arrived at the river where his boat was
moored on the day the chief and the
female slave were set on fire I noticed
that the boat had been beached and that
it was supported by four CAD Hank props
these props were surrounded by what
looked like huge structures of wood the
boat had been hauled on top of the wood
the rusia approached going to and fro
around the boat and uttering words I did
not understand the chief was still in
his grave and had not been exhumed they
produced a couch and placed it on the
boat covering it with quilts and
cushions made with byzantines silk
brocade an aged woman who they called
the angel of death turned up she spread
the coverings on the couch it is her
responsibility to sew the Chieftains
garments and prepare him properly and it
is she who kills the female slave I saw
her myself
she was gloomy and corpulent but neither
young nor old when they arrived at his
grave they removed the soil from the
wood then they removed the wood and
exhumed him dressed in the garment he
was wearing when he died I noticed that
the coldness of the climate had turned
him black they had placed alcohol fruit
and a tan burr on his grave they removed
all of this
surprisingly his course had not begun to
stink only his color had deteriorated
addressed him in trousers leggings boots
a tunic and a silk caftan with gold
buttons they placed a peaked silk cap
fringed with sable on his head they
carried him inside the yurt that was on
the ship and rested him on a quilt
propping him up with with the cushions
they placed the alcohol fruit and basil
beside him then they placed bread meat
and onions in front of him the cutter
dog into and threw it onto the boat they
placed all this weaponry beside him they
made two horses gallop into a sweat and
cut them into pieces with a sword and
threw the meat onto the boat they cut
two cows into pieces and threw them on
board as well then they produced a [ __ ]
and a hen killed them and put them on
board meanwhile the female slave who had
expressed her wish to die came and went
entering one yurt after another the
owner of the earth would have
intercourse with her and say tell your
master that I've done this out of love
for you at the time of the Friday late
afternoon prayer they brought the female
slave to an object they had built that
resembled a doorframe she stood on the
hands of the men and rose like the Sun
above the doorframe she uttered some
words and they brought her down they
lifted her up a second time and she did
what she done before they lowered her
and lifted her for third time and she
did what she'd done the last two times
then they handed her a hand
she cut off the head and cast it aside
they picked up the head and threw it
onto the boat I quizzed the interpreter
about our actions and he said the first
time they lifted her up she said look I
see my father and mother the second time
she said look I see all my dead kindred
seated the third time she said look I
see my master seated in the garden the
garden is beautiful dark green he is
with his men and his retainers he
summons me go to him they took her to
the boat and she removed both of her
bracelets handing them to the woman
called the angel of death the one who
would kill her she also removed two
anklets she was wearing handing them to
the two female slaves who had waited
upon her the daughters of the woman
known as the angel of death they lifted
her onto the boat but did not take her
into the yurt the man approached with
shields and sticks and handed her a cup
of alcohol before drinking she chanted
over it
the interpreter said to me now she bids
her female companions farewell she was
handed another cup which she took and
chanted for a long time the Crone urged
her to drink it and enter the yurt where
her master was lying I could see she was
befuddled
she went to enter the yurt but missed it
placing a head to one side of the earth
between it and the boat the Crone took
hold of her head and entered the yurt
with her the men began to bang their
shields with the sticks so that the
sound of her screaming would be drowned
out otherwise it would terrify the other
female slaves and they would not seek to
die with their masters six men entered
the eart
they all had intercourse with the female
slave and then laid her beside her
master to held her feet to her hands the
Crone called the angel of death placed a
rope around her neck with the ends
crossing one another and handed it to
two of the men to pull on she advanced
with a broad bladed dagger and began to
thrust it in between her ribs here and
there while the two men strangled her
with the rope until she died the
deceased nearest male relative came
forward he picked up a piece of wood and
set it alight he was completely naked
he walked backwards the nape of his neck
towards the boat his face towards the
people he had the ignited piece of wood
in one hand and had his other hand on
his anus he set fire to the wooden
structures under the boat the people
came forward with sticks and firewood
they each carried a lighted stick that
they threw on top of the wood the wood
caught fire then the boat the earth the
dead man the female slave and everything
else on board caught fire a fearsome
wind picked up the flames grew higher
and higher and blazed fiercely
one of the Rusia was standing beside me
I heard him speaking to the interpreter
who was with me I asked him what he had
said and he replied he said you Arabs
are a lot of fools
why is that I said because you
purposefully take your nearest and
dearest and those whom you hold in the
highest esteem and put them in the
ground where they eaten by vermin and
worms we on the other hand cremate them
there and then so that they enter the
garden on the spot they asked him about
this and he said my lord feels such
great love for him that he has sent the
wind to take him away within an hour in
fact it took scarcely an hour for the
boat the firewood the female slave and
her master to be burnt to ash and then
to very fine ash the rusia then built a
structure like a round hillock over the
reached boat and placed a large piece of
Kedah in the middle they wrote the man's
name and the name of the king of the
rusia on it then they left
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you